come back to amnesia
through the portal part 3 my name's Ben
bang uh I just started and it's like I
died Wow um I guess I quit I rage I fear
quit it before I light I haven't played
this in forever forever and never never
bro I'll uh where's my penis white as my
penis where's my pin okay I'm gonna find
your penis uh what are you doing
everyone has this the funny voice for
some reason let's go oh you look good in
pink man yeah yeah beautiful mm-hmm I
could totally kiss you right now
I'll even marry for now uh-huh there's
no one in here so I think the red one is
cool we can pull the red one bad stuff
what is that what is that what is that
what yes that we good the red one is
good mm-hmm this one looks good too
mm-hmm Bank one hey a lab pink pink one
is good I see
green one looks good yeah
Green one go the [ __ ] was that
oh okay hey hey hey hey sorry I got too
excited
so enviromental shredder okay that's
pink one looks good I'll read pull the
pink one no I didn't know no no uh from
Danielle Ron I don't I come on is
ridiculous
because a pink one isn't I think it I
was like okay we got the keys I guess
we're gonna he's hey what is it so so
here you see Piggy's here I'm here what
is he doing here I don't know I was just
falling from the ceiling
I don't know again I get hit but it was
me and you bro yo even though he's like
I mean he doesn't have a penis but I
still like it
we're still in love I'm sorry pity I
lied to you
why picking I'm sorry I mean we're
perfect for each other
just look at us just I mean look at his
look at us kissing I mean just
just I mean just just just I'll just
leave you guys alone that's so wrong
wait if I pull this long yeah I can go
bull deliver those seriously disgusting
okay we're good we good Jersey just look
at me rubbing his buddy you like when is
it give it you like when I touch you
like that this is I'm Nisha porn going
cries here oh yes you like when I rub
your sexy buddy you're like when I do
that you like when it you like when I
have my genitals in your face you like
this yeah this is something I like it I
have like 12 year olds who watch my oh
it's not good I shouldn't be doing this
I'm sorry
wait the key was four key environmental
sorry whoa it's raining pig ears I'm
pumped bump
I'm raining raining raining mm-hmm
mm-hmm
you thought I was a pig I'm rain I'm
rain [ __ ] whoa what are you doing it I
didn't know that ah oh crap wait maybe
he doesn't see me piggy you [ __ ]
[ __ ] I'm pooped
I'm not pump I can't
holy [ __ ] work holy [ __ ] I maybe make it
[ __ ] your piggy wait maybe maybe just um
again you're coming with me you're
[ __ ] out oh [ __ ] huh oh [ __ ] I
shouldn't have done that
oh not again not again late again oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] go go
go go go go go Daniel
oh that yells oh that yeah oh that oh
don't look back Daniel Oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
go that yo your bump your bum miss Bob
oh no oh [ __ ] oh oh man oh man oh man oh
man oh man
carry on apparently [ __ ] piggy that's
about it every new Tiki everyone is a
grater
I thought your finals bro then I thought
piggy was a brawl what do you make out
like Sweden i'm nita monitor let's go
let's go huh I'm sorry about that
don't touch the levers it's don't do
mm-hmm oh oh it's my bro
it's my bro Piketty piggy DP
I'll just let you guys cuddle what did I
do
[ __ ] that I do
Oh
what that I then
that's with the nice
[Music]
this does not seem good oh look look I'm
sorry about that bruh I'm sorry about
that bruh I'm sorry about that bruh I'm
sorry about that bruh
I need a gardener you got hanging out of
the bottle three bottle three bottle
three bottle oh that's it
guess go
damn him for the deed I don't know how
else he was spelled damn but everything
out like lamb man that was hot
I am lamb I am I should stop lamb lamb
lamb this place is huge
ma'am ma'am this mod is pretty done I am
lamb a ball no sexy enemy let's walk up
the stairs I just need a rest
ah [ __ ] I'm tired [ __ ] I hate stairs
okay what man it's so uh I made these
stairs stairs stairs there's I shouldn't
have eaten so many chicken McNuggets ah
okay I'm almost there ah [ __ ] stairs
ah that was worse than um nation
oh pretty lightsaber way like a name Hey
look at there so beautiful really
beautiful not looking at - really
beautiful so we click listen we go throw
the bottle I picked up the master yes
yes master oh look at that just look
attached no get at a glows when I brush
it good else good little psyched le oh
oh oh
the shadow starts immediately
ah no stairs oh [ __ ] holy [ __ ] a minute
huh sweet let's just walk for now I
wonder how that would look like in real
life is on fell down like that your
shank Oh
stairs stairs stairs stairs late stairs
at least it's better walking down them
I'm such a genius with my quotes
sometimes at least it's better to walk
down and them up man what ah what did
the game go where am i oh there we are
beautiful hey nice voicecrack I don't
voicecrack I'm a man look I'm a bad I
don't I don't do high-pitched voices or
anything I'm a mad I'm a primarily man
man main man speaking of manly man who
did anyone see that Ashton Kutcher
episode
I'm not sure if I like there or not I
like where's Ella Jean and I don't
usually watch these anyway me and I'm
like docketing no wait wait wait it's
kind of hard for you to know what I'm
saying yeah let's go back where's that
rubber ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba
monster
you know the dumb stick monster robot oh
we're in the forest
leave me some fries
yes like huh these are meatballs allow
me some meatball
why can't I walk where I want to okay
hold this once again why do I do that
is adopts a monster let's go [ __ ] you
close the door yep I did that
gross I'm sorry I'll find your penis
later oh it's okay I need to go I mean
here this is still after me seriously
it sounds like it is I hate when the
sounds comes on this freaks me out as
hell why am I wasting my lighting why
how do I know Jay mementos perhaps a
monster arm can be used in a great
underground activate in the grate on the
ground
activate portal back oh I think I need
to go back to great underground all
right am I done in here where's the
great underground how much but no I
couldn't portal and I'm like whoa what
the heck through that put through that
go through that was it bro rosen you bro
you don't have the arms how the heck did
you throw that I don't know I did it in
my mouth I spit it out that's how I spit
yeah see my arm femal I saw it so hard
that my house fell off
that's how long how do you all bidding
huh do you all huh just throw without
losing my arms I guess okay this this
one [ __ ] it wasn't that long ah
yeah ask me what it feel like Zarin a
disguise so Vendela telling Kurt Russell
homie this ain't real life I'll be
making good on my promises honesty is
confidence lot of it is listen but I
realize I could be better than I was
light on my feet
cooking up the soul when we fire up the
P